pour nancy gré obtenir ces prestations
d'assurance emploi aura été un véritable
parcours du combattant
jamais ça à peindre et alain quand on
croit ya pour après avoir été congédié
pendant un arrêt de travail pour cause
de maladie
elle sera aux bureaux de service canada
on lui refuse l'accès au programme
d'assurance emploi ne veux pas que ça
t'es malade parce que vous avez pas
contactez votre brêle quatre ans elle
conteste la décision qui finalement sera
renversée nancy vient à peine de toucher
son premier chèque
trois mois après son congédiement
franchement je sors mon judiciarise en
fait de complications aux gens les gens
ne se retrouvent plus souvent normal le
conseil national élargi des chômeurs et
chômeuses regroupe des organismes du
québec du nouveau brunswick et des
communautés autochtones
il lance une offensive cela revient aux
gens qui les paient campagne de
publicité sur les médias sociaux
pancartes dans les rues il veut attirer
l'attention des partis politiques
nous visons une refonte en profondeur du
régime d'assurance chômage
il faut dépoussiérer ses résultats le
faire débarquer au 21ème siècle
plus spécifiquement il demande que les
périodes de prestations soit allongée
actuellement elle se situe entre 14 et
45 semaines selon les régions
le conseil souhaite les voir passer à 35
semaines et même 50 semaines pour les 50
ans et plus ils demandent une
bonification du taux des prestations de
55 à 60 % l'augmentation du nombre de
semaines de prestations pour maladie
elles sont actuellement de 15 semaines
il espère qu'elle soit prolongée à 25 et
même 50 semaines pour maladie grave
cet avocat en droit du travail considère
que les réformes du système mis en place
depuis les années 90 ont affaibli le
programme accessibilité qui était rendue
plus difficile par le système des arts
pour les personnes travaillant à temps
partiel
il ya de nombreux changements de fait
pour retrouver un régime qu'ils y est
digne de ce nom il faudrait revenir très
nettement vers les années 80 le conseil
exige des engagements clairs des partis
politiques pour réformer le programme
présentement je suis très déçu je suis
très amer de caisse que je j'entends le
message est lancé qui trouvera peut-être
écho chez un futur gouvernement
ici marie josée paquet comme radio
canada montréal